just because of the nature of the good
fight i'm wondering if you have any
predictions or any ideas you might know
of of how the show's energy
might change with a new presidency on
the horizon
boy that's the 64 million dollar
question uh
i talked to the writers they were just
opening up the writer's room and they
did not know they did not know i'm i'm
hoping by now
a week later they have some idea because
do you or i know does anybody know
what inauguration day is going to be
like
i you know our show the the wonderful
thing about the good
fight it really takes place as much as
possible
in in the here and now it takes place in
this
historical moment which is why when you
know we were shooting the pilot
and donald trump won the presidency
instead of hillary clinton we had to
make a u-turn and happily we made the
show about diane's
obsession and and inability to cope with
life
in in the trump era but now that he's
gone but
will he be gone and are we going to be
living
in a post-truth world are we going to be
living
with conspiracy theories and um
you know i i don't know a plus to say
nothing
you know of uh you know covet and
how we going to do how are we going to
work in the office are we going to have
masks on are we all going to zoom
you know i i i don't know what they'll
do for the new season but it'll
it will be very ingenious because that's
who they are
yeah i feel like uh that show leaning
into current events like that it makes
me hope that it goes on as long as you
would like it to go on i know because
this show could go on because history
will
go on and it's going to probably get
even more crazy than it's already been
so i i really was
very happy to be on the show at a moment
in time when people
people were questioning what is going on
in our in our culture and in our
democracy and we were actually doing a
show with characters who were
asking those same questions and trying
to keep their bearing as
lawyers and asking moral questions and
ethical questions how do we deal with
living in this dystopian era
and i don't think any other show really
addressed it as directly as the good
[Applause]
fight
you